at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my kevin's famous chili
the trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
jake hurry up i'm starving sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry i just had to grab my
wallet
[Music]
fine i was trying something and it
didn't work hey bro
listen i was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b25
mitchell panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and i went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey ron
swanson
check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are
yeah
okay um
there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you and then
create ads for other stuff you might
want to buy so it learns information
about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to google
earth and type in your address
hey there boyle how was your weekend
well actually i got a little sick oh
really i'm sorry to hear that man yeah
bullets over broadway was on tv
i came down with a big old diane weast
infection
like
brownies i'm taking two so i can parcel
them up and eat them
at my leisure later on much healthier
you're taking two
yeah um but one of them is for tubby
yeah why don't you send that to him in
costa rica
um i'm just gonna hand it to him right
now okay weirdo
why is that why is that weird she said
she was gonna give it to him right now
she's probably going to because they sit
next to each other yeah they used to
toby works here again oh can you imagine
oh no oh you don't know
i don't know
what you should probably just meander
back there take a look see if he's see
if he's back dare i
you know what i'm going to
for old time's sake
great practical joke jim got me go to
the annex
no
god
no god please no no
no
no
901 amy santiago was officially late for
the first time ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories uh
alarm didn't go up all three alarms all
with battery backup come on who wants to
take this seriously ooh she was taken in
her sleep that's what i'm talking about
super dark boyle but way more plausible
than the sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory i bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9 a.m
why is no one working amy santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why i like to play
i'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself i'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
hot dale while they repaint the lines in
the parking lot we're asking everyone to
do street parking i'm not street parking
my mercedes well everyone is i'm doing
it cause nobody wants to steal a saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
you okay ron
just a little tooth pain i'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist ron i
don't like dentists
just a second
hey no no
no no no no no
[Applause]
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling
dentist pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see tom faint
[Laughter]
it's kind of blurry
that's better
question
what kind of bear is best
that's a ridiculous question false black
bear well that's debatable there are
basically two schools of thought fact
bears eat beets
bears
beets
battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week i was in a drug store and i saw
these glasses uh four dollars
and it only cost me seven dollars to
recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of
eleven dollars
you know what imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery so i thank you
identity theft is not a joke jim
millions of families suffer every year
michael
oh that's funny michael
accidental people what's next
um stay alive i'm getting help pull me
out you're too heavy i'd only weigh 82
pounds
save bandit
how about 911
[Music]
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay i am not dying here come on
what is
[Music]
[Applause]
attention
employees of dunder mifflin
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training exercise
so what have we learned
oh come on it's not real stanley don't
have a heart no no no no no you will not
die stanley stanley you will not die
stanley stanley barack is president
you are black sadly i'm gonna give him
mouth-to-bottom no no don't give him out
the mouth for this you're gonna swallow
his tub open your mouth michael swan
don't swallow him
i don't find you leave me alone
do you recognize any of these men i was
hiding in the bathroom stall so i didn't
see his face but
i heard him he was singing along to the
music at the bar do you remember what he
was singing i think it was that song i
want it that way backstreet boys i'm
familiar okay number one could you
please sing the opening to i want it
that way really
okay
you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one
desire
number three believe
when i
say number four i
wanted that away
i never wanna hear you
[Applause]
oh chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
god i forgot about that part
you